こんにちは
はじめしゃちょーです
はい、というわけで今回Amazonでとあるえ
Amazonかな？
Amazonじゃねえぞ、うん
これ箱はAmazonなんですけど、Amazonから取り寄せたわけではありません。
今回ちょっと特殊な粉を買いました
で粉だからちょっと今回はあの開封の舞はできないんです。申し訳ない
粉が飛び散るとやっぱね危険なのでやっぱりこういう粉ものというものはねやっぱ安全に安全に
う、うんそろそろ心配になってきました。
もう普通に開けましょう！あ、てか開いてるし
キタキタキタキタヲッ
やべちょっやべちょっとでちゃった！ね～ちょっと出ちゃったじゃん
わかってたけどね！
ほうほう、納品書
はいというわけで今回買いましたのは、
を１kg買いました。
どんなものかといいますと、ちょと見てみましょう
うわ、やば、ちょっと粉出てね？
え、これ待って
やば、死にたくない
添加物だからちとあんまりよろしくないんですよ。多分
はいというわけでポリアクリル酸ナトリウムというものを3袋買いました
合計1kgです。
まずこれがいいものか悪いのかもちょっと分かんない
ちょっと一回調べてみましょう。
ポリアクリル酸ナトリウム水分吸収率の高さを利用していると、オムツとかローションとか
ｴﾍｯ!
えへとかじゃねぇ
あと、蓄冷材・芳香剤、食品添加物にも利用されています。
すっごいいろんなことに使われているみたいで
ちょうまって危険かどうかだけ調べたい
危険性、危険性。あー良かった良かった
毒性は超低いらしいです
でもみんなあんまり真似しないでね
あーよかったそんなにね、いや危ないけどね!?
食品添加物だから多少ないとも毒性の感じはあると思うんですけども、
すごい吸水率が高い
なんかねちょとこまてよこれほホント俺にやりたかったんすよ、あの
調べたんですけど、
・・・らしいです。
水を吸うプラスチックと言われているみたい
ちょっと一回やってみましょう！
はい、ポリアクリル酸ナトリウム
ひとまずこんなぐらいにしとこう
すっごいこの吸水率の高さが魅力なんでこれがどう化けるかですね
では、ちょっと水を入れてみます
俺もう全然わかんないんだけど
ちょっと少なかったのかな
あれ～？
どうだ
はっ！
ちょいちょいちょい
あれ？俺でもポリアクリル酸ナトリウムって聞いたんだけどなー
うぅゎー
あれ？なんかさもっとこうウワッって盛り上がる予定だったんですけど・・・
もうちょっと水を入れてみましょう
ちょっと思ってたのと違うよ
もっとさバってなるハズだったのに
こい！
あれ？
あれなんかさ違うんだよ俺の中でこう水を入れるとさ
モリモリモリモリ、モリッ
ってなるハズなんだけど
なんサラサラいってる
ばーばかこぼれてんじゃん
まってわけわかんない。そして、スライムみたいになってます。
なんか違うな。俺の思い描いてた魔法の粉と全然違う。
なんでなんでなんで？おかしいおかしいおかしい
とりあえずでも今ので分かったと思うんですけど、
あれだけ水を入れても、水は降りてこなくなります。むしろ粉が落ちてきます。
なんで、吸水性はめちゃくちゃある
もっと水を入れたほうがいいのかもしんない
ちょともうちょっと水を入れてみます。
きっとそうだよ、たぶん水が少なかったんだよ。
も、もういいよ
もうド派手にいくよ
がっつり入れました。
ｳｩﾌｯ
ガッツリいくよ次は
なんで？なんでなんで？
もう違うよ
ちょっと待ってよー
ちょっと待ってよー。もう寒天ゼリーじゃないですかー。
あっつ！あっつ！あつ！熱い！
めっちゃ発熱してる！
僕は、36度5分です。
何度ぐらいなんだろ？多分絶対熱いよ
ｳｫｯ!うわ！やばいやばいやばい!
やばい
はい、今測ってみたんですけど
40.9℃です。
完全にインフルエンザ
もうなんか
も、ちょまって
な、な、な、なんな、なんなのこれね
間違いなく水を吸収しているのはわかるんですけど
僕のイメージだと水を吸収するんで、粉が水を吸水して膨張します。
そして、粉が一粒ずつ大きくなってこう粉自体が膨張するイメージだったんですけども、
今回完全に凝固しに行きました。
いや、これはちょっと実験でしたね。なんでだろう
うぅぅ...
まって、1キロも買ったんですけど...
まぁ、でもなんか無駄に使う必要もないでしょう。
なんでだろーなー
分かんないやー
吸水ポリマーというものは難しい。
またひとつ理科の勉強になったんじゃないですかね
またちょっと特殊な物質をみつけたらまた捕まえてみようと思います
ほら、ちゃんと挨拶しよ
見てくれたみんなに挨拶は？
みんな、ありがとぉう！
よかったよかった
あのね、ちゃんと次からは膨らむんだよ!
はーい。次は気をつけまーす。
よーくできました！
よし、よく言えました!
じゃまた次の動画でお会いしましょう
じゃあな！
な!